a growing number of women are travelling
for their jobs in a large majority say
personal safety is a big issue 83% of
female travelers say they have
experienced at least one safety related
concern or incident sherry Marchand I
was traveling alone for work when a man
got access to her room at an Iowa
Embassy Suites Hotel and then sexually
assaulted her she just settled a civil
suit against the hotel management and
owner CBS this morning Saturday co-host
Dana Jacobson sat down with her and it's
an interview you'll see only on CBS this
morning good morning Dana
good morning Sherry Marsh Shonda and I
spoke just days after that settlement
was reached she told me she used to
average a trip a week for work and she
took the same precaution so many of us
do in a hotel room like locking the door
and then using that safety bolt but on
this particular trip to Des Moines Iowa
another hotel guests still managed to
get into her room where she had already
gone to sleep for the night the next
thing I remember is someone touching my
leg and I it startled me I woke up it
thinking I was at home so at first I'm
like rubbing my eyes and I'm like wait a
minute
no you're in this room and then who was
this guy and so you know in these
seconds you're trying to process like
who is this person at the end of your
bed and that's when he said you're not
gonna scream ready Shari Marsh shonda's
life changed forever on April 10th 2014
after the man seen in this surveillance
video obtained a key to her hotel room
from the front desk without having to
verify his identity he entered her room
in the middle of the night sexually
assaulted and raped her for over two
hours what went through your mind if you
can even remember at that point he had
something in his hand
was it a knife was it a gun was it the
remote control I don't know but at that
moment you're so scared because you
don't know what's happening or what's
gonna happen I remember him trying to
nestle his head in my neck
I remember him pulling my pajamas off
did you try to scream even though he had
told you not to yes you you think you
are but nothing comes out you think
you're kicking and your legs don't move
and the freezing is the hardest part I
think for me because it was I'm this
tough girl and I've been traveling all
my
and you know you think if it ever
happens to you you're gonna you're in a
kick butt and in that moment you want to
survive and that's all I thought about
was surviving because I had these three
beautiful children I wanted to go home
to Marsh Shanda is a single mom of three
from Pennsylvania and at the time she
was an executive at one of the largest
frozen food manufacturers in the United
States what was the last thing maybe you
remember from when he was there with you
the last thing I remember saying to him
I'm gonna throw up I'm gonna throw up
let me throw up and he's like you're not
gonna throw up you'll be fine I went out
to the the living area and I saw like he
was gone so then I Reluctant a from the
desk and went right into the shower it
was like you're literally scrubbing your
body as hard as you can at some point I
remember being so tired I just sat down
and just cried in the tub did you think
at all I should call the police I need
to report this no I didn't even think
you don't I don't think you think in
that instance Marshawn does attacker
Christopher Lapointe was a regular guest
at this Embassy Suites
she says he approached her at the hotel
bar the night she checked in and again
the following night hours before
entering her room she says he flirted
with her and in that second encounter
described him as loud obnoxious and
visibly drunk she says she tried to keep
him at a distance eventually left the
bar and returned to her room alone you
go into your room and what did you do
you know you lock your door you put the
extra padlock that safety lock on and
you go to bed you know so what happened
my room phone rang I pick up the phone
and that's when he said you want to hang
out and I recognized the voice from from
the last two days and I said no and
that's when I said how did you get this
number and he said to me I have friends
were you nervous at this point knowing
that he knew what room you were in no
because I had to lock on I mean there
was nothing to worry about I mean you
know you get into a room that's your
safe haven no matter where you are you
know no matter what kind of hotel it is
that's kind of your place according to
court documents not only did the front
desk fail to perform a mandatory
identity check but when Lapointe first
tried to enter her room the security
latch was in place he then called the
desk to send up a maintenance man to
disable the latch again with no ID
verification in December 2014 Lapointe
pleaded guilty to sexual abuse the man
who raped you is serving 20 years in
prison but was that enough justice for
you it wasn't I wanted the people that
gave him the key to be held accountable
as well in 2015 Marsh Shonda filed a
civil suit against the companies that
owned and managed the Embassy Suites
Hotel in des moines alleging negligence
and carelessness this month they settled
for an undisclosed amount where are
things after this five years later
almost I am on one - long term
disability now which then eliminated my
position at my company I would probably
say for the first three years I thought
it was just me who was going through
this these last two years have been an
eye-opener for not only my children my
brother my dad my mom my cousins my
uncle you know when you're kind of like
that apple of somebody's eye and you
know working so hard in your career and
uncle is so proud of you have to you
know he knows what happened to you say
to you on the phone he's just so proud
of you but at the end of the day he
still looks at me like this broken
person that he just wants to put his
arms around and protect it's not an easy
story to tell why did you feel you
needed to tell it so people are aware
that when you think you're gonna go into
a hotel room and that you're gonna go to
sleep and close your eyes and that
you're safe you're not they need to
figure out a better system within the
industry to figure out how to keep
people safe atrium hospitality which
owns that franchise of Embassy Suites in
Des Moines tells us it's focused on
industry-leading safety practices to
provide for its guests the company added
that the terms of the settlement are
confidential John Q Hammonds which
managed the hotel has no comment at the
I'm really free now Tori she's already
settled so Sheree's speaking out because
she wants to make sure this doesn't
happen anybody else exactly because it's
one of those situations so many of us
find ourselves in and you cannot believe
as you all said to me at that moment the
safety latch was undone and all of your
jaws drop I had no idea they could break
it like that - yeah unbelievable a
lesson for all of us when we're away and
we're actually going to get into that
tomorrow it's it's a rare incident but
it's not isolated in recent years there
have actually been several similar cases
reported and tomorrow we're going to
have more on that in the ways that women
travelers can try to protect themselves
all of us really it's a really important
story Dana thank you thank you